si bien los periódicos británicos se
mostraron comprensivos algunos usuarios
en las redes sociales dejaron mensajes
racistas en las cuentas de los tres
jugadores que fallaron sus penaltis en
la final de la euro 2021 contra italia
lo que provocó que el entrenador gareth
southgate saliera en su defensa
es mi decisión quien patea los penaltis
no se trata de que los jugadores se
ofrezcan como voluntarios o que
jugadores con más experiencia decidan no
hacerlo esa fue mi decisión la de nadie
más que algunos de ellos sean abusados
es imperdonable de verdad al principio
del campeonato el primer ministro
británico boris johnson no había
condenado a los aficionados que
abucheaban a los jugadores por
arrodillarse antes de cada partido
en un gesto anti racista pero el lunes
condenó el abuso este equipo de
inglaterra merece ser elogiado como eres
no ha abusado racialmente en las redes
sociales los responsables de este
espantoso abuso deberían avergonzarse de
sí mismos la policía metropolitana dijo
que había iniciado una investigación
mientras que otros usuarios en las redes
sociales se lanzaron al contraataque
inundando las cuentas
jugadores con comentarios positivos en
un intento por ahogar a los racistas
pero los ataques no solo son en línea en
manchester un mural del jugador marcus
fráncfort fue vandalizado con grafitis
racistas es más deprimente no es así
vivimos en un país donde este tipo de
respuesta es la nueva normalidad ahora
este racismo parece ser cada vez más
frecuente ahora no cree en gran bretaña
está cada vez más polarizada aunque
también puede ser una señal de que más
víctimas se están pronunciando los
delitos de odio por motivos raciales se
han más que duplicado desde 2012